President Trump tried to enlist top
intelligence officials to refute the FBI
investigation into possible Russian
collusion CBS News has learned that the
president separately contacted the
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates and the director of the National
Security Agency Admiral Mike Rogers now
this was first reported by The
Washington Post both men reportedly
refused to comply with the request which
they deemed to be inappropriate Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
intelligence are set to testify today
Nancy good morning good morning this is
sure to come up repeatedly on Capitol
Hill today because first off here in
front of the House Intelligence
Committee you've got the former CIA
director John Brennan testifying he was
at the helm of the agency during the
period in which Russian election
interference took place and then across
the capital the Director of National
Intelligence dan coates who you just
mentioned was already scheduled to
testify but is now sure to be asked
about what exactly the president said to
him our job here is to provide the best
intelligence we can to the policy makers
the Director of National Intelligence
dan coates said this month that
investigating Russian interference is a
priority but mr. Trump made separate
appeals to Coates and to the director of
the National Security Agency asking them
to publicly deny the existence of any
evidence of his campaigns collusion with
Russia in February the president
allegedly issued a similar request to
the now ousted FBI director James Comey
asking him to halt the investigation
looking into former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and his
potentially illegal contacts with
Russian officials on Monday
Flynn denied a Senate request if you're
innocent why you taking the Fifth
Amendment candidate Trump denounced the
tactic but now Flynn is refusing to
testify or provide documents to the
Senate Intelligence Committee in a
six-page letter Flynn's legal team said
that he is the target of outrageous
allegations that feed the escalating
public frenzy against him Intelligence
Committee Chairman Richard Burr said he
is still deciding what to do about it
documents obtained by the House
Oversight Committee also indicate Flynn
may have lied during his 2016 security
clearance renewal Flynn told
investigators he was paid by US
companies for a 2015 trip to Moscow when
he was actually paid by the state-run
Russian media outlet RT New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie who initially
ran the Trump transition team said he
warned the president to steer clear of
Flynn
if I were president the United States I
wouldn't let general Flynn in the White
House let alone keep my job the newly
appointed special counsel Robert Muller
has now met with FBI agents who have
been conducting the investigation and
we're told that the former FBI director
James Comey wants to meet with Muller as
well before he testifies before the
Senate Intelligence Committee in a
couple of weeks Charlie thanks Nancy